Kip.
And.
Hello, Andy.
Let me admit, Andrea.
Hello, Andrea, how are you?
Pre.
Hello, I'm fine, thanks. How are you doing?
I'm doing good.
Oh, good.
So, how was the day so far?
Ah, so far so good. Busy, but so far so good.
How about you?
So we, it was good so far, a lot of meetings this morning.
So far, nothing bad has happened yet.
Been busy a little, Monday meetings, you know, so back to back.
Yes.
Yep.
So, how was the weekend then?
It was good. It was good. The weather's finally improving, so that always puts me in a good mood.
It's getting hot here.
I bet.
Too, yeah, too hard.
We're grateful when it's 72 here.
So we have Andy here. Hey, Andy.
Andy.
Hello, Andrea.
No Kip.
Left.
So, Andrea, how are things going with Sameer?
I think that they're going well. She continues to.
Catch on and do a good job.
Okay, that's great. Is Kris also going to join this meeting?
I think so. Let me check.
No, he seems to be on another call, so I guess it's just going to be us.
Okay.
Okay, great. So any feedback you would like to share with something?
Not that I can think of right now.
I think she's doing a good job. She's always there when I need her.
Okay.
Yeah, I understand. Yep.
Yeah.
All right, so let me share my screen real quick, then we will go through the presentation then.
Okay.
Let me know, Andrea, once you are able to see my screen.
I can see it now.
Okay, great. So once again, welcome to our bi-weekly business review. And this is for the last two weeks, starting 27th of April till May 8th.
The agenda would be the same. Started with check-in, highlights, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of your customer, way forward, and recap.
And we already talked about how things are going with Sameer and thank you for sharing the feedback for her.
Moving on to the highlights, so...
We have been getting good feedback with Sameer. She's doing a good job. She's capable, pleasant, reliable.
Her ticket notes were also appreciated along with her thorough documentation. And we also discussed somebody to proactively reach out to Kris sooner whenever she's stuck on any issue.
But.
Regarding the KPI discussion.
I have been working with Kaseya Support.
I will send an email to Kris as well regarding the progress and I have a call scheduled with Casia support this Wednesday or Thursday.
Pre.
regarding the reporting that we were trying to set up in Autotask.
Okay.
Yeah, and additionally, some team has requested videos from 26th May till 29th for four days on the occasion of Eid.
Sure.
It's a festival in here in India, when celebrated globally as well.
Sure, she can just fill out the form here to request the time off and then we will fill it out for her.
Sure.
I will ask her to do that, sure.
Because we are closed on the 25th because it's a holiday. So yeah, so we'll be off that day. Everybody is off that day. It's a national holiday.
And regarding...
Okay.
Yes, yes, it's from Memorial Day. OK, great.
Yes.
And for regarding the CSAT survey, I will send an email to Kris as well to fill out the pending CSAT survey for some rain for the month of March and April.
Sure.
So moving on to the action tracker, I've been working with Kaseya support on building the KPI reports. And Sameer is working on her level up, and we are expecting her to finish it by the end of May.
Okay.
These are the ITBD recommended KPIs we already discussed with Kris. And let's jump into the performance analysis.
So this is her utilization for the last two weeks. Her average utilization had been 64%.
So in the from 27th April to the 1st May it was 63 and then it increased a little bit in the last week.
Any question on this, Andrea?
No, looks good.
At.
Key.
Moving on to her ticket data, so this is also aligned with our utilization in.
From 27th April till 1st May, it was a bit low. He worked on 38 tickets and closed 14. And in the last week, the ticket flow was high, so she worked on 59 tickets and closed 23. So in total, he worked on, she worked on 97 tickets and closed 37 of them.
And moving forward, she, as we discussed earlier, so she need to proactively reach out to Kris whenever she's stuck on any issue or ticket. And she will, we will continue to support her to close more tickets effectively.
This is our Build It Live 2026. Andy, would you like to take over? No, Kris is not here, but still we can share this information with Andrea.
Definitely, Kip, thank you for that opportunity. Andrea, you might already be getting my emails regarding Build It. Are you aware about the agenda and all what we do at Build It, or shall I explain it to you?
Yes.
No, I'm very aware of it, but I will not be able to attend because I'm needed here at the office, especially in the summertime when people are going on vacation.
Okay.
Okay. Okay.
Okay, anybody else planning to visit Builder to this time from your company?
I haven't been informed, so I couldn't say.
Okay, okay, right, right, right, Andrea. And I'll continue to provide information as we get information and we'll see because there is quite some time now for the build it. Somebody might plan out by that time. Thank you. Back to you, Kip.
Sure.
Okay.
Sure. Thank you. Thank you, Andy. Thank you, Andrea. And this is the AI by Design. Again, this has already been shared with Kris. And this is our team GPS in-house tool.
And...
That's it.
OK.
Any question, any suggestion, any feedback you want to share?
Not that I can think of.
Okay, and for some rains videos, I will send email as well to Kris as well. And I will ask her to fill that, fill out that form.
Sure.
Right, in auto-task, there's a place where you go to request the time off.
Yeah, in our path.
Yes, I will ask her to do that as well.
And we need to reschedule our next meeting because that is currently scheduled on a holiday. So if you're available the 26th, we can just move it up to the 26th.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, we can. We can definitely. Okay, I will do that. Same time would work. 26 same time.
Okay.
Okay. Yes, same time is good, yeah.
Okay, okay, I will do that. I will reschedule it.
So thank you. Thank you, Andrea, for your time today, and have a wonderful rest of the day and week.
Thank you, same to you.
Yep, yep.
Pleasant weather.
Yes, thank you.
Blake.
Bye-bye.